I think this might be part of your new
book but is it something that you talked
about in terms of getting self-absorbed
in Hollywood what is that what does it
look like that's all so we can define it
well I think it being self-absorbed
looks pretty much the same in every town
and country across the globe you know
it's you I see it in other people often
when they just don't you know you know
sometimes you're walking down the street
and someone goes hi and you're
absent-minded you're thinking about
something else and you respond just fine
you know you're in your own head and
there are a lot of people in this town
but everywhere that are in their own
heads and they don't they don't ever ask
about you they never they and they're
not good ball players you know I mean a
conversation you pass the ball and if
you don't pass the ball then you're
having a monologue and that's not really
that interesting to people and that's
what it looks like to me there's a
there's this one actress that I
encounter all the time she absolutely
knows who I am
but every time she meets me it's the
first time and we have gone up against
each other for four roles and and I've
gotten some of them and she's gotten
some of them but there is I think a lot
of the people who are the most
self-absorbed are also those who are the
most threatened who who feel that if
they are not focused on themselves and
what it is they need and what it is they
want and what it is that perhaps you can
deliver to them then they're not taking
care of business you know they have to
be you know it's all about the next
thing and and that sort of reminds me of
the of this man that I when I forgot my
first television show I was going to
celebrate and I took myself out to
place called Joe Allen's it's called
something else now and it's quite a
popular place but I don't remember and
my father was an actor and I my parents
divorced when I was very young and he
was a fantastic actor and I think that I
gravitate although I've written and
acted since I could write or speak
I think I'd pursued acting in a way to
kind of bring my father closer to me at
least metaphysically psychologically and
so he was the first one I called my
mother had supported me my whole life
but my father was the first one I wanted
to call and say that I got my first job
in TV so I went to this bar and called
him from a pay phone do you remember
what those are anything and he and I
told him about it and he was because he
was a little jealous himself because he
was self-absorbed you know and instead
of being joyful for his daughter even
though he was my father and we wouldn't
ever go up for the same parts I had
landed something that was really good
and he couldn't really support me in
that you know he was and I my spirit
really felt a wound I have you played it
off because you know that's how I rolled
but i but i but it hurt me and but I
said all right he is but that I shook it
right off and I said he is not gonna
crunch my buzz I'm gonna carry on with
this celebration so I went to the bar
and I bought myself a cocktail and I was
chatting with a bartender and then a man
came in and he's and I struck up a
conversation and and I was facing him
and he was facing the door and and and
he was you know he was talking to me
but but I but I could see that he was
always looking at the door he was always
waiting if every time the door opens
somebody can because he was you know I
was nobody I was just some girl with a
bar you know and and he was waiting for
somebody more important than I or
someone who could do something for him I
couldn't watch tit I watched his face as
he was you know it was I I was just a
time I was a space holder
and sure enough somebody came in and
that he knew or that he started to chat
up that was and he dropped me as though
he had never
seen me before in his life he didn't
even say lovely talking with you my pals
here nothing like that you just and I
watched him like a scientist because I
could see it happening maybe it was my
father's recent sort of lack of
enthusiasm for my job but that got me
primed for this but I watched this guy
as I said like a like a scientist and
and I thought the casual rudeness and
disregard that I saw and still see in
this town is really it was no longer
surprising but it is remarkable it is
worthy of remark anon you know because
it has nothing to do with you or me or
whoever is the one who is the recipient
of the rudeness it says everything about
the person who hasn't any social grace
or any you know experience in sharing
life I think there's almost like this
acceptable level of that here which I'm
well study
it shouldn't be but I think yeah it can
be a where they kind of people need to
size you up what can you okay this
person can't do any three for me then
move on I'm moving on right but I wanted
to go back to the parent thing only that
I've seen two types of performers here
and those are people that have and I
wouldn't call them stage parents but
parents that just follow everything they
do and they're the biggest supporters of
them and then I've seen the exact
opposite I don't usually see a lot of
gray area of those that oh that's nice
dear okay and they change the subject
and I think it's interesting that you
were there to take care of yourself to
celebrate for you what would you say to
people that don't have the parent that's
the cheerleader get your tribe find your
people make your family and stick with
them and support them and and and let
them support you and take care of
yourself make sure that you support you
right you know it's you because very
rarely are members of
same family conceived or born under the
same roof you know haven't you noticed
that you've collected family you're
chosen your friends are the family that
you choose and and so it's it's nice I
know everybody wants their parents
approval that's really important I mean
you can see all kinds of psychological
damage done to children who are now
grown adults who are still striving for
the love of their parent or the approval
of their father or their mother or
something like that it's a struggle but
you know you be there for you and and
allow yourself to celebrate other people
don't have to celebrate you you can
celebrate yourself and it's not
big-headed
or anything it's let the universe know
thank you something good has happened
this is terrific and and even if you're
celebrating it by yourself however you
celebrate it you know with a taco and a
horchata or a glass of champagne or
meeting somebody and let's go to the
movies or let's go for a walk on the
beach or fly a kite or whatever but do
it because we let all of these moments
go by all of these celebratory moments
that that and then we think we've just
been living this kind of life when we
could have been living this kind of life
in this kind of life this kind of life
but then the you know it's a we have to
acknowledge the moments if you don't
acknowledge it it's I think it's like
with any relationship a human
relationship you know if someone does
something for you and you acknowledge it
it increases by many-fold
the likelihood that they will do another
nice thing for you so if the universe is
doing nice things for you and you go for
me hmm don't hurt the universe's
feelings for goodness sake
you know you you you need to acknowledge
it encourages it stimulates the flow of
more good things to celebrate yeah like
people don't do that until a major upset
or death happens and I don't mean get so
morbid but it's you I know what you
think it's those those moments in life
that call everything into question oh my
god
you know I now I look around all these
deaths that we've had in the last year
of all these musicians who are in there
like late 50s or 60 years old or
something way too young to go I can
remember when I was 14 my boyfriend and
I and his mother drove down to to
Connecticut to see his grandfather and
they were sitting around the table and
they were and my boyfriend asked about
how's mr. Smith's down the road yes oh
he died only 70 such a young man and up
until that moment I had never thought of
life or age as relative I thought of it
as you know whatever the opposite of
relative is that you know that you know
I'm fourteen seventy that's a million
years old but suddenly I saw this man
who was himself only 69 or something
look at 70 as being young and then I
realized oh my gosh
it is it's why are we waiting to realize
that life is worth living right now you
know why do we need mr. Smith down the
road to die
at the very young age of 70 for us to
start thinking about the days that we
have because you know what and this is
not more but this is just the truth
no one knows no one knows that's true
when when their time has come you know
so if you keep waiting to to have your
adventures or to celebrate or oh I have
a really fun one to share with oh yeah
okay okay
you